on va jouer avec l'abus de confiance et
abus de confiance et c'est le mensonge
et le renard les chroniqueurs sont ils
des arnaqueurs qui est le meilleur
arnaqueurs nous allons le voir chacun va
venir raconter une histoire
un auditeur votre téléphone s'il dit
l'histoire est vrai qu'elle est vraie il
gagne une clé qui correspond à ses
coffres ouvrir le coffre
il gagnera ce qui est à l'intérieur à la
fin avec toutes les clés gilles de quoi
s'agit-il
l'orage gronde sur cuba la sarre est un
jeu l'orage gronde sur cuba en tout 15 h
le l'orage gronde sur cuba nous sommes
en 2003 le malecon à la havane et
transpercés par la furie des eaux
mes vacances commence très mal je viens
de débarquer à l'aéroport et je me suis
aperçu qu'on m'avait dérobée ou que ma
valise était perdu donc je vais voir les
responsables de la compagnie d'aviation
qui me disent mais voilà on prend note
elle est peut-être égarée on sait pas
bref je me rachète quelques habits comme
ça vite fait et j'arrive à mon hôtel je
passe une soirée catastrophique
le lendemain matin coup de vol j'ai
toujours pas ma valise mais je vois un
gars qui porte ma chemise
pourquoi je sais que c'est ma chemise
parce qu'avec moi pour porter des
chemises hawaïennes ridicule je joue
juste une parenthèse je souhaite pour
toi crient les la bonne clé parce que
les autres ne passeront pas je n'ose pas
aller voir le gars mais je vais voir la
direction de l'hôtel j'ai dit mais j'ai
perdu en espagnol j'ai perdu ma valise
hier et là je vois un gars qui a ma
chemise dont il a ma valise allons
fouiller sa chambre le directeur de
l'hôtel ne veux pas je le convainc on
frappe à la porte du gars je vois le
gars qui était français en plus je le
reconnais il était dans l'avion d'hier
et je lui dis vous avez volé ma valise
et le gars dit non on fout la chambre on
fouille tout est évidemment ce n'était
pas ma valise voilà je mets ma chemise
c'était tout ça c'est ça la chute des
cours très bien alors à ton avis allison
j'écoute le gall et qu il aurait dû
c'est très bien selon lui reproche à
l'essonne arnaque ou vérité c'est de
l'arnaqué
gilles c'est de l'arnaqué
c'est en 1981 secondes
ouais 1989 je suis journaliste pour la
première fois jeudi au festival de
cannes
et figurez-vous que j'étais à l'époque
dans un super je travaille dans un
supermarché
donc je me suis débrouillé comme je
pouvais et figurez vous que j'y suis
allé dans l'avion du président de la
république au supermarché
non au festival de cannes
voilà c'est tout voilà il a brillé au
vrai la vie auquel président françois
mitterrand alors est-ce qu'il était sain
parce que vous lui avez parlé j'étais
pas avec lui c'était un avion du glam
vous savez là le service de transport du
président est-ce que vous avez alors à
votre avis merci parce que l'imitation
était pourrie mais tu ris quand même
gémeauxla que tu es sympa et charitable
avec moi sk ton avis il a pris l'avion
avec françois mitterrand dans un avion
du glam ce que j'ai pris l'avion du
président de la cnil est un essai ah non
c'était vrai c'était vrai on perd là
très bien reçu je joue en contre
je suis je vous rassure tout de suite on
la raconte rapport donc j'étais avec ma
mère en voiture sept ou huit ans elle
est en train de produire actuelle est
donc ça sentait à cigarettes et en fait
j'ai pris dans la boîte à gants quelque
chose que je pensais être du parfum sauf
que c'était pas du tout du parfum
c'était une bombe lacrymo et j'ai tout
temps beau mais on a eu un accident de
voiture on a fait trois tonneaux très
bien voilà toute ma famille est décédé
dans l'accident
vous avez pris de la bombe lacrymogène
elle était en train de conduire vous
avez aimé par tout à ça que c'était dû
parfois tonneaux et vous étiez d'or
qu'il y avait d'autres dans la voiture
un ami à moi même et ça ça me met sur le
dos façon là sur le coffre low cost a
fallu avec toi et ma mère n'allait pas
et h et donc du coup j'ai raconté
l'histoire vous c'est ça je sais cela
comprendra les concurrents alors atteint
la vie on est ce qu'il y ait eu à les
belles si elle est vraie elle est
impressionnante
est-ce qu effectivement elle s'est
trompée lamit de la bombe lacrymo neige
lacrymogènes pardon la tête de sa mère
et a provoqué un accident vrai et c'est
totalement vrai on travaille alors il ya
moins de 10 1 points il m'est arrivé en
2008 quand je commençais dans la radio
il ya des petits boutons sous les tables
de mixage pour rappeler comme dans les
banques
si jamais un jour on est attaqué par un
mec a marre mais un petit bouton de
sécurité et on est fort mais quand on
arrive à la radio à l'utilité ce bouton
sauf que les stagiaires ne sont pas
formés et pendant une émission
stagiaires nettoyer derrière avec une
petite éponge et avec une petite brosse
à dents la table et il a appuyé sur ce
bouton
moi j'ai continué à parler et cinq
minutes plus tard il ya des hommes
cagoulés qui sont rentrés dans gg haut
l'équivalent du gène en belgique qui est
arrivé qui a bloqué la route avec deux
camions noir et ils sont montés à une
diz quinzaine à peu près dans le studio
avec les lasers et c'était mon petit
stage à qui s'appelle khalid que
j'embrasse et qui est totalement resté
en prison on le rappelle inscrits nous
regardent avec est ce que c'est vrai ce
que sans vouloir kelly d'appuyer sur le
bouton et a fait venir la police dans le
studio de radio en belgique
pourquoi pas c'est vraiment c'est vrai
tout à fait vrai elle aimerait occuper